OH! CUPHEAD is a little difficult. BOO HOO HOO!
OH! You think Cuphead - you think Cuphead is hard?
You haven't played "I Wanna Be The Guy"
I don't think you have, I don't think you have. Have you played any other game in your gah *pewdie moan*
You have to do this. Listen, you have to do THIS
stupid thing. EVERYTIME, ah? You have got to this [intense  music]
(Pewds get pissed) BOO HOO HOO! And you've got to do this
And then they go faster
and then THIS jump!
Is Impossible. It is impossible
I have done the math, okay? I have a 4% chance of making this jump
4%! And after I do the 4% jump, I have to do all that!!! And I dont even know
What to do when that happens. [death music]
Oh Look at that, Cuphead is a little hard. You know dare I say this game is just like Dark Souls
Even though it came out before dark- I can't even do the first jump. They managed to put
a flippity damn
Rocket on the moon, okay, I can make this jump. I know I can make this jump (sigh)
I need to make this jump (death)
*sigh*
Nooo! That's where I run okay. I see it now. I see it now I can visualize it! I can visualize the jump
There is hope (oh)
Flick dammidioogie slappadabba
Flaca! Come on, what do I do?
How? How? he just went for it, dude
Wait, he just double jumped through it!
You can't just double jump through it! T_T
Oh, you just have to do that!? Are u serious?!? Oh my gah!
*Pewds sobbing* oh my gah, I just had to double jump. I just had to do a god damn double jump. That's all I had to do
Why did no one tell me!? That's fine
We gotta kill these bats, and I don't know how
Okay, all right, here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go, come on, come on
I never want to play this a- thing again, and this can actually happen
Okay
Where's the bat?
Got'em
Swacka lacka lacka pracka! Okay there's another one
There's another one
Where are you?
The creature of the [dies] fuck! *Brad starts talking with a movie trailer voice* Coming soon to a Cineplex near you
I should have thought from the look of the poor fellow that he died of fright
Beware the terrifying creatures!
Yvonne Romain and Oliver Reed. Beware the creature of the fuck.
the creature of the- fuck
*RIP*
Whatever, I can do it now. I can do it easy.
First try, watch me.
Whatever.
First try baby first- awww....
my god you
Moron! Where are you? I know you're coming for me. I know you're coming for me. where are yah!?
Bring it! bring it!
BRINGIT! ooh ooh ohh!
*Loud Breath*
Upstairs. They came from upstairs! He came from downstairs
Gah! BRRRRUH! *hissing noises*
Life's not fairrrr ;_;
It's fine... It's fine!
It's fine dude! It's cool man. It's cool! Don't worry about it!
It's all good. it's all good man. *Pewds sound*
He's got good. He's got good everybody. And he...he's very beginning to believe
Badabada badaba Christian channel, Felix.
Christian channel. The ad revenue, it will all be for nothing.
Kerchow, kerchow, kerchow, brabababa, brabababa
*Brad's trailer voice over voice: And so began Pewdiepie's slow descent into madness*
*Until eventually he would transform into... The Creature of the Fuck!*
It's gonna come from underneath you will attack from underneath. He will attack from underneath
What the flicker!?
*Pewdiepie Insanity Noises*
CHRISTIAN CHANNEL... URG NO CHRISTIAN CHANNEL... CHRISTIAN CHANNEL... FUCK.
Cuphead is a little difficult. Huehueheuheuheu Cuphead. Cuphead is another- *Deep inhale*
We're not done yet
We're not done yet. Why the flicker am I shooting that way? Okay, okay?
There might be more bats Felix
Be alert. why didn't the *gasp*
Hit it! Hit it!
You, you thought I couldn't do it. My haters doubted me *dabs*
*Pewdiepie euphoric sounds*
I might cho- choke on my own mucus.
Ahhh sweet euphoria man... sweet *incomprehensible pewds*
oooooooh Christian Channel!
*Pewds still in euphoria in background*
Oh wow, he did it!
He did it everybody!
Well another challenge
This feeling is so good.
We have saved. We have saved the damn game. We have saved it. How many deaths was that? How many deaths was that?
Can I check it somehow?
*UUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUHHHHHHHHHH*
Options. Play. Hide the menu
Disable..I don't
I'm just gonna quit it okay. Hopefully it's saved
Okay, it didn't even count any of the deaths last episode. Just keep that in mind
*Zero Deaths* Oh my God.
So this jump looks pretty straightforward. I don't know--Okay
It's a little tricky actually.
How in the world-?
How in the? how? how? how? how? how!?
War....Has changed
*"How" continues*
Sorry. Why do they have to make the first jump impossible?
Oh I get it
oh my god
*Swedish*
Noooo. No no no
No, no no no no, I refuse
We take me back. Thank you
Yes, yes
YAS QUEEN YAS. Can I get a hallelujah?
hallelujah
Hello, hello signore. Thank you. Thank you, you did it!
splendid mast- master Wayne
*Swedish again*
Look at that! Easy. Easy. Easy.
This Game. Game is a little easy.
I will say.
How do I activate the arm, huh? how do I activate the arm?
Goodbye, arm, goodbye. Not on my watch. BYE! I'm going. Oh, I can't go there. Okay. All right
We got apples. We got apples, we got zombies
What's gonna happen?
Hmmm eheh
First try. first try. first try. ZERO. ZERO. ZERO deaths. Zero deaths
Zero deaths
That's a bird. FUCK OFF bird. I hate you. Okay. Okay, okay? I got it. I got it. I got it
Ah apples!
Fucking apples. you gotta get the views
Felix... Think of the views
Think of the views and everything will be okay.
That's right. Views....views.
*Pewdie repeating "views"*
Think of the children.
NO!! Come on!
Come on. I show them. I will record everything.
More stupid apples
stupid zombies
Stupid b-apples, go away!
Show! show! (Shoo! Shoo!)
Do the damn jump Felix! Do the double jump! No, this is bad. Oh, there's no save-there's no save yet
Are you fracking it backening me man?
You can't be serious right now. How am I supposed to do that?
Aw, that's IMPOSSIBLE! THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE! THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE!
I am the one, who don't weigh a ton
Don't need a gun, to get respekt (to get respect)
Up on the street. Under the sun.
And my enemies my enemies I won't- oh god, a zombie. Faaaahk a Maka
And I have to do all of that. No thank you.
Thank you. No, thank you goodbye!